I mean most about CM Punk was there he
has the the WWE back on you would think
he would least be like great on the mic
you don't I mean they're like maybe we
can't back it up or fight over like he
goes from my cocky and confident I'm the
vodka champ or whatever that would be
eats like huh you know I just believe in
yourself kids thank you it's like really
hard listen it don't believe me it has
no physical like no physique he doesn't
least not like it's kind of sad I just
[ __ ] on CM Punk no listen you didn't
[ __ ] on me so you were honest about him
you were honest about what you saw I
don't think that's [ __ ] on him he's
a very nice guy he's a very nice guy and
he's a hard worker but he does not have
athletic talent he's missing a lot and
he's a showman and when he was in the
WWE he was allowed to say I'm not
[ __ ] Mayer and throw his arms up
there and they had it scripted so that
he was the man but you know when you're
in there with a guy like Mike Jackson
who had zero fear of him and just was so
casual and just popping him in the face
anytime he wanted to and literally could
stop him anytime if he just got angry
and want to stop him he could have
stopped him at any point in the fight
and even though he beat him decisively
the performance was a piss Dana White
off so bad the way he was fighting that
he'd called him a [ __ ] idiot and he
said he'll never fight in the UFC again
and he won so like if Mike Jackson went
out there and just start CM Punk with a
right hand left hook combination and
that was the end of it they would say
well CM Punk you'd give it a shot that's
it it's over Mike who would you like to
fight next and now it's like you know
you're not even fighting in the UFC
anymore
because you should have you should have
stopped him like what you were doing he
tickled him yeah you [ __ ] don't make
a joke of the sport like it's already
like a joke if this guy you know
everyone thinks CM Punk's like a [ __ ]
joke I guess he is that's where they
look but like don't make a joke of the
sport and like not you know yeah they
kind of just like poking fun at the fans
I get where Dina's coming from
I get where dreams come with us - I just
arched him yeah it's the whole thing was
it was very weird the whole thing was
very weird it was like right away when
you see CM Punk holdings holding his
hands up and moving stiff and throwing
kicks like oh Jesus like I don't like
that being on pay-per-view I understand
they're selling
pay per view cards but pay-per-view in
the UFC should be the elite fighters
curtis blades vs alistair overeem should
have been on that pay-per-view card
that's what should have been they're not
not what we got to see you know what we
got to see was just yeah i don't like
when it's like now like you're playing a
trick on the fence you know any mean
you're promoting this guy is it'd be
something and it's like yeah sparring
videos come out and it's like what the
[ __ ] is this barn videos were crazy and
it's awful it was like a guy who just
showed that off are awful it's like you
took a dude who's no wrestling
background no nothing and you know this
one won't you do this is a jab this is a
right hand and this is when you throw a
kick I want you to pivot your hips good
and there as far I mean he just he
doesn't have the ability to move his
body right there's a lot of guys you
could take out there that are tracking
field guys or football players and you
could get them to fight better than him
in a couple of weeks right easily cuz
there are athletes they're athletes they
would understand how to shift their
weight throw a punch and yeah that the
sparring videos that I saw was that and
he was from his first fight but even
then like he wasn't he signed for like
two years before he had his first fight
or something
yes but there's no way that you six
years deep in the game idiot you still
in that bad you know I mean it doesn't
have any talent it's all it is it just
doesn't have physical talent whatever
for whatever reason whether it's his
approach his intensity whether it's it's
not as coaching so what Duke [ __ ]
Rufus you know yeah I mean well the
house is do the coach I mean that he
talks about Duke Rufus he and then one
of the pre fights he said uh how do you
see this fight he's like I'd really like
a head kick Duke would love to see a
head kick like I don't think that's
gonna happen oh that's so crazy that is
so that's such a crazy thing to say um
you know Duke's a beautiful person he's
a great guy in every every sense of the
word he just says he's a great guy he
did his best you know there's only so
much you could do I know I mean I'm sure
you would love working with Duke I'm
sure he would love working with you if
you and Duke work together I'm sure you
guys would have a great old time because
you're Joe [ __ ] chillings right and
he's Duke [ __ ] River though you know
let him know
but you know what I mean I mean you have
to have something to work with you know
I mean if Duke just grabbed some dude
from a gas station that has been
drinking beer and smoking cigarettes his
whole life and and had him in a fight in
six months how much can you possibly
hope but I would rather see that fight
again see that's fine well a guy who can
find it a gas station beer and say
what's interesting is they both both
guys fought Mickey Gaul first just weird
did you see his Instagram Miki's yeah he
didn't like his own pre-fight uh
analysis of how it was gonna go it was
really good yeah well you know that was
a disaster
when I saw Mickey fight and then I saw
that he was gonna fight
CM Punk I was like who said yes to this
why the [ __ ] would you say yes to this
this is a hundred percent guaranteed
brain damage there's no way you're gonna
beat him there's not you don't have a
goddamn chance in hell you have no
chance and I was saying that people get
mad at me - CM Punk fans getting mad at
me I'm like look this is what I do my
job is to analyze [ __ ] I look at I look
at fighters I look at move I understand
what I'm talking about man
this is like I'm got a pitbull and I'm
gonna put them in a cage with a puppy
what do you thinks gonna happen
the pitbulls gonna kill the puppy this
is what this is how it works
this isn't like this isn't glut maybe
that puppy could grab them by the face
no no no no listen to me I'm telling you
guys this is how bad this matchup is
this is a this is a Brazilian Jujitsu
brown belt with a nasty back game well I
mean let's get wrong and fast you look
at a matchup with that CM Punk just had
Mike Jackson Mickey beep my checks in
and I'm like under a minute right yeah
smushed him took his back strangle him
he said he's uh
but I heard training with me for like
three months now and the kids getting
really good his striking is getting
really really good
he's [ __ ] talented man really good
and he talks a lot of [ __ ] - yeah he's
good plus he's got hilarious walkout
music when he comes out - oh there was
he got here I called his phone it's like
you know those people have those ring
back songs and they're like [ __ ]
horrible yeah he answers I'm like dude
turn that [ __ ] [ __ ] off you change it
or at least have it be hey Mickey you're
so fine yeah and what is
music videos on some trash it's just
just elevator like something oh [ __ ]
change it Mickey that's changing